the realm
do you know what the realm is
[Music]
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video
well that was certainly one hell of an
episode as always there were some things
i really liked and there were some
things that i did not like about the
episode
i thought about recording my thoughts as
soon as it was over but my emotions were
still very high so i decided to watch
the episode again
then sleep on it before i made a video
now that i have had some extra time to
think about everything
i want to talk about the battle for
king's landing let's start right at the
beginning of the episode when we see
varys writing letters about jon's claim
to the iron throne
this is a moment we have been leading up
to for quite some time
well varys was actually right daenerys
did exactly what he thought she
would do he knew daenerys would bring
fire and blood to the streets of king's
landing
it's hard to say exactly how many
letters varus was able to send out
before he was caught but i would like to
think that some of his ravens did reach
their location
therefore john's secret will no longer
be a secret between a few characters
when we see varys writing those letters
one of his little birds comes into the
room to talk to him about danny
you have to wonder how long she has been
working for varys because they were
together down in the crypts of
winterfell
he was most likely setting things in
motion long before he ever revealed his
intentions to tyria lannister in the
last episode
varys had indicated he would have
daenerys targaryen killed
and it seems like that is exactly what
he was trying to do in this episode
varys little bird says that dany has not
been eating any food so it does seem as
if varys was having her deliver some to
dany
because he was most likely trying to
poison the food if you remember all the
way back in the first season this is the
same way they tried to kill danny when
she went to the wine merchant
i hope to repay your kindness someday
something wrong i have a thirst open it
the one is for the kalisa it's not for
the likes of you open it
whatever arrangements you made
unmake them at once
i'm afraid those birds have flown
the girl is likely dead already
varys did help set that in motion as
well we then see tyrion watching as
varus talks to jon on the beats of
dragonstone
this leads to him telling daenerys of
his treason because he now knows
varys has taken things a step further by
doing this right under dany's nose
varys often works behind the scenes in
the shadows but now he's walking right
up the jaw on the beach in the middle of
the day
before he can even get the words out
danny says she already knows someone is
betraying her
danny was basically waiting for this to
happen because jon already indicated he
would tell his family the truth
danny knew that as soon as sansa found
out she would tell others in hopes of
john taking the iron throne before she
could we all saw what danny just did to
king's landing so what could that mean
for sansa now that she has taken the
gloves off
danny also made it very clear to tyrion
he will not be getting any second
chances
he was foolish for thinking sansa only
told him the truth because she trusted
him
dany has only known sansa for a short
amount of time yet she already knows
what sanza is actually trying to do
now that dany has taken down cersei
lannister and her army
she will now focus on those around her
that are not on her side
anyone that she sees as someone who may
have crossed her could be facing some
serious consequences
dany further indicates this in her next
scene when her and jon speak together
she knows that sansa once are gone and
she reminds jon that sons have broken
their trust by telling others his secret
danny will absolutely want something
done about that there is no way that
dany could be comfortable on the iron
throne if she knows her so-called allies
are actively trying to remove her
either dany has to go or sansa has to go
that leaves john in a very tough
position
because he obviously has love for both
of them not to mention he is related to
sansa
and he is related to danny we are now
starting to see that jon will have to
draw a line
in the sand danny still wants a
different kind of love from jon
however now that he knows they're
related he can no longer continue the
same relationship they once had
he basically tells danny i love you but
i'm not in love with you
if you know what i mean dany realizes
that no one in westeros loves her the
way that she wants
in her mind she has already came to save
all of them which she already kind of
did when she helped john defeat the army
of the dead but that apparently isn't
enough
they're still not ready to accept her
and now that everything else is falling
apart around danny
this moves her closer and closer to the
breaking point she more or less says
alright
fine if they don't want to love me then
let them fear me
her friends are dead her other dragons
are dead john no longer loves her like
he once did
his family hates her and her only other
advisor cannot be trusted anymore
all she really has on her side is her
dragon so why not become one herself
then we get the execution of lord varys
he tried to cover up the evidence once
before by burning the letters but this
time we see him take the rings off of
his fingers
that may have been more varus was hiding
the poison kinda like how it was in
sansa's necklace during joffrey's
wedding
unfortunately for varys it's already too
late the cat is already out of the bag
daenerys was basically emotionless when
she killed varys
and it even looked like jon was a little
unsettled by that but what's done is
done
i saw this coming from a mile away let's
go to the next scene where tyrion and
greyworm talk to danny
this is when dany is really starting to
show signs of not caring about the
people in king's landing
tyrion says what he can to try to get
dany to see that all of them don't
deserve to die
she doesn't have to burn the entire city
to win the battle he tries to convince
her to stop the fighting as soon as the
bells start to ring
that will be the sign that the city has
fell and everyone is surrendering
now danny does agree to this but she
hesitates ever so slightly
it's almost as if she begrudgingly
accepts tyrion's wishes
danny even looks over a grey worm and
even he doesn't seem to want to agree
with it either
unfortunately they do not want to see
cersei or her men surrender
they want everyone to attack because
they are out for blood and they
obviously do not want to stop until
everyone is dead
it's actually very sad to see characters
become that dark
but this is only the beginning right as
the scene is about to end danny tells
him about jaime getting captured by her
men
now she knows jaime wants to go back to
cersei if you remember back at
winterfell when jaime first arrived
danny did not want him getting off so
easily basically everyone in the room
besides her agreed to let jimmy stay
danny accepted their advice once again
and it ended up blowing up in her face
once again
i'm actually a little surprised that
danny did not have jimmy killed almost
immediately after his capture
danny does however make it very clear to
tyrion you will not be getting any
second chances
your advice has screwed me over one too
many times i've had enough
so what does tyrion do next he goes to
see jaime to let him free
the first thing he does is go to davos
because as we all know davos is the
greatest smuggler in westeros after all
he was the one that got tyrion in the
king's landing last season
now i can't believe that davos would
even agree to do this for tyrion and
jaime
this very well could get davos executed
by dany
i mean now you know why dany is getting
so paranoid everyone on her side is
working right behind her back
there is no way that jon snow would
agree to letting davos do something like
that for jaime
i don't care if he did help them fight
the army of the dead or not jaime had no
intentions of trying to kill cersei
or even help all the citizens in king's
landing all he really cared about was
getting back to cersei which was very
frustrating for me
we have seen jaime come so far as a
character just to see him revert right
back to his old self
he even said to tyrion i never cared
about the people in king's landing
and i thought that was a crazy thing to
say considering jaime nearly got himself
executed to save all of them when he
killed the mad king
remember that amazing scene when jaime
and brian were bathing together
how many men have you killed my lord
i don't know 50 100
countless countless has a nice ring to
it
how many lives have you saved half a
million
the population of kings landing
tell me if your precious brandy
commanded you to kill your own father
and stand by one of thousands of men
women and children planned alive would
you have done it
but you've kept your oath then
jaime said in that scene what would you
do if your king wanted you to stand by
while he murdered thousands of innocent
lives but now
for some reason jaime no longer cares
about them i could not believe jimmy was
about to do this
now besides all that i really did love
how the scene ended
i did like that tyrion was able to tell
jaime just how much he has meant to him
he was absolutely right when he said
jaime was the only one who actually
cared about him
and she said he killed my mother and she
pinched your little [ __ ] so hard i
thought she might pull it off
until your brother made her stop it
doesn't matter
she told us everyone says he will die
soon
i hope they are right he should not have
lived this long
his other family members wanted to see
him dead from the moment that he was
born but jaime was the only one who was
always there
he was the only one who never looked at
him as if he were some kind of a monster
and i can understand why he would want
to set his brother free even if it meant
his own life
i think most of us would try to do the
same thing for someone we really loved
not to mention he was really counting on
the fact that jaime would change his
mind and do the right thing by making
sure the city surrendered before
everyone had to die
now this is something tyrion will have
to answer for later
the unsullied men who were guarding
jaime know that it was tyrion who saw
him last
it will be fairly obvious that he was
the one that set jaime free
now i wonder if davos will have to
answer for this because he is the one
who made sure jaime got off dragonstone
and back over to king's landing
he may have to face consequences as well
and right now
danny's not in a very good mood now
let's get to the scenes in king's
landing
when everyone was getting into position
it felt very intense and i absolutely
loved it
the shots of king's landing looked
amazing euron's fleet out on the
blackwater bay looked amazing
the golden company marching down the
streets looked badass
then we saw arya and the hound moving
around the city trying to get to the red
keep
then we had jaime moving around the city
trying to get to the red keep
i was on the edge of my seat during the
whole time i kept thinking who's gonna
get the cersei first who's gonna get the
cersei first will it be danny
arya jamie who knows but i can't wait to
see what happens next
then we saw the golden company line up
right outside of the city gate
i could not wait to see how well they
could fight because we kept here and
cersei has 20 000 mercenaries who are
well trained
and well rested they even showed harry
strickland the same way they showed jon
snow right before the battle of the
bastards
the camera was behind him and it slowly
rolled up his back to show the army on
the opposite side
and i was thinking damn this dude might
be able to kick some serious ass
now besides jamie wanting to go back to
cersei i did like everything else in the
episode leading up to the battle
everything i talked about so far i did
enjoy without really any issues other
than jaime
but then the battle started and well
it was obviously extremely one-sided the
golden company sucked
these 20 000 so-called mercenaries
looked like a bunch of [ __ ]
harry strickland was very disappointing
even his death was pathetic
we then begin to see daenerys wipe out
everything with ease
in the last episode we saw the scorpions
kill regal within the matter of seconds
but now they have even more scorpions
but they don't even land one shot on
drogon who is a much bigger target i
might add
now you could say yes drogon is bigger
but he's also faster
also drogon has a writer and daenerys
displays exactly how dangerous a dragon
is when it comes to directing it when
and where to go at all times
dany begins to wipe out cersei's army by
the thousands and honestly they didn't
even stand a chance
jon barely even had to swing his own
sword now another thing that really
annoyed me about jaime is he had the
opportunity to ring the bell before he
got to cersei
in the middle of the battle when it's
complete chaos jaime is still trying to
find a way to get inside of the red key
right before tyrion set him free he said
that he would try to get cersei to make
them surrender
however jaime should have been able to
ring the damn bell on his own
he could see that the city was already
falling around him but he selfishly
wanted to get to cersei regardless of
how many died on the streets
now when it came to cersei during this
battle i wasn't exactly sure
why she still thought she could win even
after she saw how bad things were
getting
i almost started to laugh when she said
that city will not fall
the red keep has never fell i could not
tell if she was just very confident or
if she was in denial
or maybe a little bit of both anyways
now let's get to what everyone is
talking about
the moment in which daenerys decides to
turn king's landing into a living hell
the bells begin to ring but daenerys is
not satisfied by their easy surrender
this causes dany to snap you see dany
gave cersei the opportunity to surrender
before anyone had to die but cersei did
not accept
now king's landing is surrendering
almost immediately
which dany most likely feels like
missandei and rhaegal died for nothing
why did that have to happen if they were
just going to give up so easily
then you add to that all the other
losses dany has had to face
and all the characters around her trying
to cause her downfall
so she loses it and i have to say i was
absolutely shocked by this
not because danny turned into a mad
queen that has been a theory for over a
decade i always knew that could happen
but what i was not expecting is how
relentless danny was
after she lost it danny was burning the
civilians for
almost 30 minutes of the episode or
that's at least what it felt like
i remember very late into the episode
when it felt like it was over
i thought she has to be done there is no
way she is still burning everything
then the scene cuts back to danny's
dragon still burning the streets and i
was like holy [ __ ] will this ever stop
now i was hoping that danny would burn
all of cersei's soldiers
i was hoping that danny would burn down
the red key i was even ready to accept a
little bit of collateral damage but this
i cannot accept
and i don't care how upset danny was you
cannot justify those actions
i even saw some fans say well they all
deserved it
they were cheering for ned stark to get
executed well there is maybe only a few
hundred at ned's execution
and most of them were adults danny was
killing children who weren't even alive
when ned was executed
now imagine if that were you and your
child out there running on the streets
would you think you deserved to die just
because you lived in that city
i don't think so and yes she was killing
them intentionally
that was not collateral damage that was
murder
now on the other hand it absolutely felt
rushed
yes danny has shown some signs of
madness before but nothing like this
i think if they did want to have danny
do something like that then we should
have seen her kill some innocent
civilians on smaller scales leading up
to this
every other time dany burnt someone
alive it felt justified
i don't think it would have been as
shocking if we seen danny target some
civilians in other smaller battles
before this big one
now if i take a step back and just look
at it as someone who likes to watch
television
it looked incredible getting to see that
kind of chaos in king's landing makes
for one hell of an episode
like i said i was on the edge of my seat
the entire time i also did like how we
were able to see the wildfire getting
set off during the scenes of the battle
danny and bran's visions also came true
like most of us knew they would
the dragon flew over king's landing and
the red keep was
massacred but then we see a lame ass
euron and jaime fight on the beach
the only thing i really liked about the
scene was when it reminded me of what
jaime once said to ned stark back in the
first season
so will you tell yourself at night
you're a servant of justice that you
were avenging my father when you shove
your sword in aries targaryen's back
tell me if i stab the mad king in the
belly instead of the back
would you admire me more when they were
talking about jaime killing the mad king
jaime said something along the lines of
would you have admired me more
if i stabbed the mad king in the belly
instead of the back
i don't know if this was meant to be a
call back or not but it did work for me
because the fatal blow was when jaime
stabbed euron in the belly
i also did really like when the hound
was finally able to fight his brother
this was very predictable but it was
also very satisfying for me
now right before that does happen arya
and the hound do have a nice final
moment together
i kind of saw this as the hound making
arya realize getting your revenge is not
worth your own life
you really don't want to live your
entire life where you're only motivated
by hate
and wanting to get that revenge against
those who have done you or your family
wrong
cersei was about to die anyway so why
stay here to kill her when it's going to
cost you your own life
now it was very interesting when we saw
the mountain no longer wanting to obey
cersei or qyburn's commands the
clegane's hatred for one another runs so
deep that not even his masters could
contain him i do kind of wish that we
would have got to see cersei's head
slam against the rock just like qyburn's
that would have been a hell of a lot
more satisfying than seeing her have the
chance to run
right back into jaime's arms again i
can't even begin to tell you how
disappointed i was when cersei lannister
died the way that she did
for everything that she has done and
caused over the years i really wanted to
see her suffer for it
anyways for a few moments i wasn't sure
if the hound was going to win the fight
or not
his brother was almost able to do the
same finishing move that he did to ober
martel
now what's kind of funny is the hound
actually got the upper hand by doing
what arya once said she would do to him
he stuck the blade right through his eye
and out the back of his skull
someday i'm gonna put a sword through
your eye and out the back of your skull
and of course speaking of arya stark the
episode more or less ends with her
running through the streets trying to
find some cover
she does try to help a mother and her
daughter get to safety but danny runs
both of them down in the street
i'm sure most of you noticed this
already but the little girl was holding
a white horse in her hand
and interestingly enough it's a white
horse that somehow appears out of
nowhere to give arya a ride out of the
city
now arya does see the mother and the
child again but they were burned alive
the horse in her hand is also very
reminiscent of the one that davos gave
to shireen baratheon
when it comes to the white horse i think
most would agree that it most likely
represents death
which does fit with arya's star given
her storyline throughout most of the
show not only her time with the faceless
men
but also the phrase what do we say to
the god of death not today
now does it mean that arya stark will
take that white horse to go kill danny
some say that she does have green eyes
so maybe arya kills her for burning
everyone in the city
well we know that arya could kill dany
if she really wanted to but i think
someone else will kill danny before it's
all said and done
most of you already know who that is
i'll just leave it at that because i
don't want to spoil it for others who
may not want to know
anyways that's all i really have to say
about this episode comment down below
and let me know what you think
i want to thank everyone for watching
the video and i also want to thank
everyone for supporting the channel
i hope you all have a great day i'll see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
so
you